questo gioco contiene immagini forti
suchan scherzi le robe che tanto ciò
dieci anni di youtube l so perfettamente
belle cose belle tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono file
e oggi si alzò psic sai quanto ho fatto
bene il menu play ragazzi si preannuncia
un gioco della madonna è passato un
intero anno da quando ho visto la mia
famiglia un incidente dopo l'incidente
sono stato in ospedale per tanto tempo
non mi ricordo dell'incidente l'unica
cosa che mi ricordo e che ho guidato la
macchina fuori dalla strada in tutto
questo ecco ci
siamo beh va bene questo non è proprio
dal mio cane bellissimo messaggio al mio
cane pronti
messaggio bellissimo che ha schiacciato
su messaggi samantha ti sto aspettando
da al telefono vicino al ponte che non
sono nati al pont des coletto you can
find insurance o che è variata poi a
sinistra quando quando passi l'entrata
va bene allora stanno succedendo due
cose 1 c'è una pagina dello slam germain
ok
c'è veramente la pagina dello slider me
va bene
e poi c'è un telefono si sia il bond
cabina del telefono eccoci
porca [ __ ] che succede tifava la testa
prendi un momento un momento zio il
momento non c'è telefono in su che cosa
che squillavano eccolo qua a ieri
assiste con judy other side of the ponte
cassi the last hope that qualcuno che ha
rapito mia sorella a strozzo andiamo
alle ogr side of the pond che non so
dove sia
bellissimo la torcia che
funzionano proveniente come non averla è
una merda andare dall'altra parte
ragazzi credo che sia di qua non ci
metto la mano sul fuoco perché non ho
capito bene però costi fischi che fa
stima perché siamo questo qua è
manicomio tra sicuri si può giocare a
scacchi qualcuno gioca a scacchi con me
nessuno
sono redditi su tex in yes sono seduto
avrei voluto tenermi dove c'è la
scacchiera posso spegnere
nessuno ci fosse qualcuno parte che non
mi chiederei però va bene siamo seduti
non c'è nessuno con chi stai parlando il
sito spiega me
pensa che sia uno scherzo fatto dalla
sorella questo non credo sia uno scherzo
della sorella non vedo neanche nessuno
che si che prende posto davanti a me
quindi siamo qua
mi hanno puntato una pistola
la mia piccola sorella sun ha rubato
qualcosa che non le appartiene qualcosa
dai valori in menti me ne abbiamo
parlato in un posto sicuro
lei ha detto che
c'è un puzzle da risolvere va bene il
puzzle e am applicato nougat ott beh va
bene devo risolvere un puzzle ma da
storditori e giallo mal di testa grazie
dunque
pronto ti ho dato la droga che ti
dovrebbe uccidere dopo un'ora quindi
abbiamo quindici minuti prima che abbia
effetto quindi tra 15 minuti muoio va
bene bella notizia
ma un ios e la 106 disse abbiamo una
chance per per salvarsi e salvare mia
sorella o lo scorso l'antidoto con un
codice il primo indizio per il codice e
alla cabina del telefono buona fortuna
minchia 15 minuti ciò prima di morire sì
ma svegliati che c'è tempo ma scuola il
tempo davvero o no una finta sta col
sole 22 l'a22 porto sono morto ok
fratello mio posso darti un consiglio
visto che stai per morire io le bambine
le muoverei un po più veloce però poi
fai sentiamo io voglio assolutamente
condizionarti 6 lato la vita è tua però
io le gambine le muoverei comunque
cabina del telefono primo indizio va
bene
c'è la scatola con l'antico bisogna
giocare un po heavy rain meno scatola
con eccolo qua entra number comi
i fianchi e penso giudici da lei che la
pace psicologa do you get comi se tu
aggiungi le prime due digit
invece sì qualche cosa brand allora 911
e classico american emergency col
ma se aggiungiamo le prime due digit e
129 11 progetto no perfetto
non ho ben capito però va bene sarà
giusto
ok
questi sono i primi tre delle quattro di
cistite cose
ma pure difesa da un dio benedetto dio
ma che cazzo ma quale via per il culo di
yen chance non sarà l'entrata va bene è
un e sky per un aria fuga se non corri
adesso mi paga all'ultimo però anche la
scatola donna po di ricorrere zio stai
morendo
credo che l'indizio sia nella macchina
non so cosa me lo fa pensare a jared
però si fisso qua quindi in giro con me
alla fine avete comunque riesce a fare
sta cosa senti ho capito cosa cazzo devo
fare
eccola la boxe è mancato anche un codice
aspetto stato spetta esci non lo so e
scelte non lo so non so esci diretto
riusciva poi uscire esci e scena stato
uscirà la scatola l'essere umano è
infinito nella sua valutava questa è la
traduzione italiana non c'è nessuno i
trinakant perfetto quindi 101 siamo
ancora alle 22 e questo mi rende felice
l'essere umano è finito nella sua valuta
investendo quindi 101 infinito il codice
non so ai 18 perché volte all'infinito
quindi 10 18
vado finché albertone ma chi sono ma
cos'ha giucas casella sono bellissimo
penati fi nale onore ho letto fidate
fidati da l'antidoto buono buono stanti
lo sono trovato subito
e beh non è il momento sicuramente devo
trovare samb il mio cane abitativo qua
dentro non lo trovi sta correndo ai 600
allora non lo prendi manco solo paghi
cosa ne so io lì dov'era dove di dovere
a mia sorella che cazzo ne so sorella
fatelo lei matteo anno ok mi sta
indicando la via pazzesco vogliono tre
passi c'è la luce per i lucci che
l'altra guarda perfezionare ad un
silente che toglie
l'ampia più fisico o
avanti così
alessandro nova io mi guarderei più
indietro che davanti mi sto pagando
addosso
ma chi e cosa non ho capito niente
ma cosa vecchio for black cosa dove non
ho capito niente di quello che so niente
non ho capito niente di quello che è
successo ma quanto colto questo gioco
era cortissimo ragazzina tremendamente
corto sto gioco ma perché la demo allora
vi faccio un breve riassunto questo si è
svegliato il manicomio fuori dal
manicomio con un telefono di dubbia
qualità e stato interrogato perché
cercava la sorella e poi la sorella e
applicato una testata questo è comunque
belgio senso attendiamo tutti gioco
completo per adesso spero che vi sia
piaciuto di serie era un po corto però
sai com'è tra sorelle katie piccante
state droghe passeggere ma per la
gelosia in chiave jazz non ci vediamo
come sempre un momento mi piace qui
sotto e fatemi sapere pensate del gioco
come pensate che si evolve la situazione
anche perché non ci capivo niente o se
trovate un riassunto migliore del mio
faccio anche la rendiamo un attimo una
questione di riassunti chi lo riassume
meglio vince il commento fissato in alto
del video ok quindi riassume temi meglio
il gioco come potete da cosa che mi fa
più ridere la pink'o in alto comunque
ragazzi per ora concludiamo qua
iscriviti al canale ragazzi e nociglia
come ed ai ragazzi
[Musica]